depuis 5h un matin je reçois des
téléphones
la famille de la petite madison avait de
quoi célébrer ce vendredi matin la
fillette qui souffrent des milieux
autres finales de type e pourra
finalement recevoir le médicament solgan
sma c'est comme si on se réveillera d'un
cochon tel qu'un petit réveil d'un
vilain cauchemar puis le soulagement que
tout cas c'était qu'un rêve le board
vrai qu'on est comme ça qu on est encore
un peu dans maladie
québec a annoncé que cette thérapie
génique la première pour traiter cette
maladie sera ajouté à la liste de
médicaments fournis en établissement de
santé grâce à une négociation entre la
compagnie pharmaceutique et les
provinces le gouvernement du québec a pu
obtenir prix acceptable pour le all
games makiko d'habituel man 2 millions
huit cent mille dollars au total dix
petits québécois pourront en bénéficier
je vous dis moi j'avais des frissons
mais là dedans parce que je me disais le
mois de novembre pour moi c'était comme
ma date limite pour madison et là on est
en octobre le 20 octobre le médicament
sera disponible lui les organismes en
est administrée tôt plus il est efficace
on maximisera donc les chances de survie
de madison puisqu'elle recevra avant
l'âge de six mois la maladie sera
toujours présente mais sa qualité de vie
sera grandement améliorée on veut miser
vraiment les gains et les pertes parce
qu'ils étaient les pertes vont être
moindre ça va vraiment freiner la
maladie le gouvernement du québec espère
pouvoir dépister la maladie dès la
naissance pour prévenir ce genre de
scénario on va essayer même de continuer
la recherche au niveau du dépistage au
niveau natale quand un enfant naît est
ce qu'on pourrait tout de suite vérité
par terre c'est tous les tests qu'on
fait quand les enfants naissent si
l'enfant est atteint de l'amyotrophie
spinale à partir de maintenant la
famille de madison pourra profiter des
bons moments à venir voire plus se
concentrer sur elle l'effectif au
travers tous ses collègues de fond là
des fois on essayait ton était plus
fatigué à partir de maintenant va pas pu
se concentrer sur lycées respect ses
progrès pour ce qui est des quelque 650
mille dollars qui avaient été amassés en
dons par la famille ils seront
remboursés aux personnes qui souhaitent
récupérer leur argent quant au montant
reste à il sera remis à une fondation
ici fait les pleurs radio canada
saguenay